foreign
so I want to hone in on the idea that
it's a research project and that it
began with certain questions that maybe
um you've articulated already and ask
the the further question which is
whether it succeeded in answering the
early core questions with which it began
um so Maria would you mind if we start
with you so has the our first things has
analytic philosophy actually been able
to address the core questions with which
it began well like we've been discussing
I think it depends on what what these
core questions or aims were because uh
if if we take the core question or aim
to be
let's see how
philosophical problems can be a case of
confusion and drawing the right
distinctions between the different
logical roles that a word a word can
have can help us avoid some pseudo
problems then I think it has succeeded
because it has been helpful in in making
us kind of see that and work on that now
as Barry was saying there was also a
project of kind of moving away from
ordinary language and building an ideal
language and then that depends on what
the aims wear for that so as you said
like Freddie the grief shrift concept
notation like an ideal language that we
could use philosophers could use to
avoid all these confusions that get us
to all the kind of the problems
um but then also that went too far
because
like with karnab and logical positivism
you have the idea that
um
for language for language to be
meaningful at all you must either have
propositions that are in verifiable
empirically or logical propositions in
all other areas just disappear so think
of what that would mean for areas like
ethics Aesthetics and it's not just
areas it's all like aspects of Our Lives
because the concept of the good for
example it's not just when we when we
talk about ethics but think of how it it
uh permits our our life as a whole
anyway but so so if that was the the aim
I think to some extent it failed and it
it couldn't but fail but again there was
a mention of of Wittgenstein and
especially the later like when you have
the transition that meaning is is not
just something a temporary historical
but you also have to look at the use so
the interesting thing is how do you keep
both how do you keep you know as you say
the excitement and I think it's a very
philosophical like it's a very platonic
thing too of of trying to look at
something clearly undisturbed from all
sorts of things that can't disturb you
but on the other hand also how can you
take into account history and the fact
that you are you know situated in space
and time so
so given the complexity if we then take
the one of the core questions to be how
does ordinary language fit in so not
just an ideal language but how does
ordinary language fit in
um the way we do philosophy how can we
take that into account in a way that is
helpful I think that's also a core
question and I think this is still being
explored and it's a good question so the
jury is still out on some of them
there's options in any case thank you
very much
um Hillary you've been quite clear that
it does not succeed
perhaps you could say a little bit more
about what you took the the key question
to be and exactly why you think it fails
well uh you know it it as I say I I was
enthusiastic about it as a as a as a
young student
um for all of the reasons that Barry
described it was in the 19
uh tens and twenties and 30s it was a
dynamic new uh brush through what had
become a rather
um
uh
impenetrable hegelianism which had
dominated a lot of philosophy
um so that was very exciting but but
that was 110 years ago
and and
um uh during that time there have been
both the initial
flaw which Wittgenstein identified
very early on
and uh there had been attempts to carry
on the project in one form or another
because it's a very attractive thing you
know philosophers like this thing oh
we'll turn philosophy into a science you
know science gets all of the you know uh
accolades and we want to no longer be in
a space where we're just wandering
around between different different views
we'd like to make slow piecemeal
progress like science so it's it's got a
great sort of vision to it the the
trouble is that it it it it just hasn't
functioned like that and I think it
doesn't function like that because the
the core analytic project has set out
and I think Russell is you know he he
was the person who started using the
word logical analysis and he does have
an overall philosophy uh he was a
brilliant mathematician he he provided a
logical frame for mathematics along with
Whitehead and he thought you could then
apply it to language and there was
nothing wrong with that Vision it was a
very exciting Vision it was just I think
mistaken the that um you can't just
apply logic and Mathematics to language
because that's the relationship between
language in the world is not the same as
the relationship between mathematics and
its proofs and and I think the history
of an active philosophy people who've
identified themselves now for analytic
forces it exhibits that and and uh
uh so and it's just that we we want a
more diverse more more encompassing uh
philosophical conversation which
involves radically different uh
philosophical views and challenges the
big questions of our time of how we
should make sense of the world
um rather than somehow to assume that
this those sorts of logical principles
are really making progress okay so Barry
um you identify the initial project with
fraga's project
do you think that has been successful
yes and no
um so I I think I think Hillary is
absolutely right the the the the key
problem was if you were uh trying to
just Define a very special formalized
language special rigorous language that
was not like ours and it was for the use
of mathematics and and it was logically
very precise then it was doing its job
to capture some facts about mathematics
but but why assume that that was a model
for how language would work beyond the
mathematical Realm
but the other thing is it didn't even
work in its own terms because Fraga also
had the ambition to to try and explain
what mathematics was and he tried to
reduce it to logic certainly try to
reduce arithmetic to logic because he
thought logic was certain and if we
could at least stop there then we if we
could reduce uh arithmetic logic we
we've got a justification for arithmetic
it didn't work Russell tried it it
didn't work
so in some sense it didn't do the full
philosophical job but but more
interestingly I think was
philosophy stopped for analytic
philosophy shouldn't be fossilized you
shouldn't think of it as what it was in
the 1930s and there are some people for
whom it's still 1930 on their watch and
we know that but uh you know there was a
move away from putting language at the
center of philosophy and thinking if we
analyze language we'll sort of find our
relation to the world and so on there
was a in my time there was a move to the
philosophy of mind being all important
and suddenly we were dealing with mind
and we were looking at again it was
often driven by
uh what was going on in science
Neuroscience is coming up Psychology was
developing and so suddenly philosophers
thought we need to understand the Mind
better and and then language takes a
second role because instead of thinking
the big job is understanding how
language relates to the world a much
more interesting question is how does
language relate to thought and indeed
you know what we're doing now is using
language to go public on what we're
thinking and language is an interface
between Minds that's really interesting
it's the way in which Minds can make
available to each other what they're
thinking where there's no barrier where
we're not having to guess what's going
on in someone's head and understanding
kind of languages are all not as this
you know big starting place for
metaphysics but is much more soon into
our activities and much more part of the
human situation I think the person who
helped us get there of course was
Wittgenstein as Maria said because
Frankenstein stopped doing the job of
tidying up language and said look at
language and see how it is there's
nothing wrong with it it works as it's
doing now I presume for all of you I
hope we don't have to problematize it
and worry about it it's doing just fine
our difficulties accepting it as it is
okay thank you very much so um let me
just try and get at the fault lines of
the debate there so has it succeeded in
answering its core questions Maria you
want to say it um it depends kind of how
you specify the questions but certainly
to some extent it has I think Hillary
and Barry are both you're in
disagreement sorry you're in agreement
about the failure of the core questions
but you disagree about the value of the
methodology perhaps or the approach to
philosophy so you think it can be
updated and um when looking at different
philosophical problematics like the
philosophy of mind and I feel Hillary
that people perhaps more suspicious
but if we could move on to the um the
next theme which tries to take that
philosophical question about the value
um and apply it to current uh debates
that are divisive in our culture I
wonder what you have to say about that
so to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas